all right let me talk about something
that that happened over the weekend
um as many of you know uh when the
latest
israeli-palestinian uh flare-up
took place um at first
for the first four or so days i i didn't
say anything about it
feeling i didn't really have too much to
add i heard from some people
respectfully who said hey you should
talk about this
um and then so i did and i did a
20-minute segment it's over the last
month it's the only 20-minute segment
i've done and that was a couple of weeks
ago and throughout
before i talked about it and after the
anti-semitic comments raining down on
our youtube channel
raining down on twitter instagram we
we've had to block
tw twitch thousands uh close to a
thousand people i would say i don't want
to exaggerate
certainly hundreds of people on youtube
about a hundred on uh on twitter
call it 600 to 800 people probably okay
to not not be hyperbolic which is you
know a lot for a program our size
and even after i did the segment the
anti-semitic comments about me being a
jew rat or all of this different stuff
they just didn't stop and at a certain
point it sort of becomes clear that
you're not really
contacting me about foreign policy
anymore it's just anti-semitism that's
really what it is
this crossed over to the real world and
over the weekend i was
um out with some friends for dinner uh
at um at a restaurant and
um we were there sort of a lot of things
are still closing early in the northeast
um because of covid guidelines and so
there were very few people left
and as i was leaving um i walked by
someone
who kind of gave me a weird look and i
didn't know if it was
that you know i had some borscht on my
face like that one time where i did an
entire show
with with borscht on my face and
producer pat didn't tell me
or maybe they recognized me i didn't
really know walked past them
and when i'm 30 feet away um
i hear pacman and i turn around
and they yell at me you jew
zionist imperialist
now uh i just turned and walked away i
didn't
engage with it and i think in general
what these people want
is a reaction and who knows if they plan
to film me and put it on twitter or
whatever the case
um but i just i just walked away
and you know this what what's really
obviously this is not fun um but
people come up to me all the time and
typically they're
they're positive experiences and i do a
show that's public and so
to some degree this is this is bound to
happen but
um you know this is this was a quote
left winger
right this this is not a right winger
this is an issue that it's it's more
often the left
the right does a lot of anti-semitism
with me uh but they say go back to
israel
right the right-wing anti-semitism is go
back to israel a place i've been once in
my life for
nine days um the this is this was some
something from the left
and so i think it should be clear to all
of us at this point
that this is not a critique of my
position
right it's not it's not even really an
argument as many of you know
uh i have more than a decade on record
of being
unquestionably critical of uh
settlements
the netanyahu administration the urgency
with which we need to find a way to lift
the blockade
i'm not going to do the segment and see
this is the problem
why am i even talking about policy
because this incident was not about
policy
i've spoken about you know the
israeli-palestinian conflict
really once in the last two years and so
jew zionist imperialist um is not even
plausibly
a critique of my policy and uh
all sorts of things are going off here
so what do we do about something like
this
i don't know i don't really plan to do
anything about it
there's a there's a real problem with
anti-semitism on the right and we've
covered it for a really long time we
just reviewed on a recent live stream
uh that white nationalist dude who
wanted craig cobb who wanted a
whites-only enclave
in one of the dakotas and he was overtly
anti-semitic during our interview and
that's very clearly a right-wing
anti-semitism
unfortunately there's a left-wing
anti-semitism as well
and uh even by talking about this
there's going to be even more that's
hurled at me and some people are going
to write and say
well it's not anti-semitism david
because you are a zionist and as i've
always said before
what do you even mean by that term every
time i've been confronted with it
um i never really get a straight answer
and what i've said before is if what
you're asking me is do i
think that the solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict is no more
israel
no i don't think that's the solution
much like
the solution is not no no palestinian
state
right i think the solution is an israeli
state in a palestinian state
does it does that make me a zionist uh
because otherwise it's never anything
we're able to actually figure out but
hurling jew
zionist imperialist to someone you know
on the street
um is is over the line it's not a policy
critique
i don't know what else to say about it
but if the left goes
too far in this direction um
it's not going to be good and as i said
before
it's counterproductive it's
counterproductive because
every time jewish folks hear
about not what happened to me what
happened to me was not violent wasn't
physically violent but what we
we've the videos we saw from los angeles
new york etc
more and more american jews or jews
wherever they're being harassed in
france
say wow i really may need
to move to israel someday and they
disengage
from holding israel accountable for the
things israel does wrong so not only do
i think it's ugly and disgusting
it's also counterproductive to what most
of these leftists claim to want
i think that's all i really feel the
need to say about it
maybe something i'll follow up on at
some point in the future but
really ugly stuff unbecoming unbecoming
of the left